[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yay
[Music]
so
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
do
you
do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
do
do
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
me
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
that's what i'm talking about
hello
[Music]
so
[Music]
happened
yo check this out
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
don't check this out
thanks
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
2021 and you know here's the truth guys
sometimes the
most difficult decision discussions
rather are the ones that you need to
have the most and
with the gaming community already being
such a diverse place
it's time for the creative space to
reflect that so
here's take two with an important
discussion on the necessity of diversity
equity and inclusion and the corporate
responsibility
to honor those things
[Music]
hello i'm alan lewis vice president of
corporate communications and public
affairs for take two interactive thank
you for joining us today and welcome
to virtual e3 2021
take two like many organizations is
deeply committed to
and actively involved in numerous
initiatives to enhance diversity equity
and inclusion
within our society and industry
affecting
meaningful sustainable change is a
continuous process and there is no
one solution that can achieve that goal
we believe that to enact change
especially for those in underserved and
underrepresented communities
there needs to be a continuum of
activism and engagement
with educational programs serving as its
core foundation
beginning with children in elementary
school we have the ability
to light a spark of creativity
intellectual curiosity
and wonder that can last a lifetime
continuing through middle and high
school we can support and nurture
students during their formative years
and increase the depth of their skills
that can provide a pathway to attending
one of 400 plus colleges and
universities
within the united states that offer
degrees in game design
providing opportunities to attend these
academic institutions
including need-based financial support
is
also a critical component to helping end
generational cycles of inequality
and while pursuing their creative and
technical degrees
students can learn firsthand from
industry leaders that share their
experience
acumen and passion through one-on-one
mentoring and internships at our
organization
together if our industry can execute
this continuum
we will have invested meaningfully in
the lives of the youth from these
communities
for more than a decade before they begin
their professional journey
diversity and inclusion make us a better
industry for today
and most importantly for tomorrow it
allows us to make better entertainment
experiences
that are authentic culturally relevant
and reflective of the audiences that
enjoy them
today we have brought together a few of
our important partners
who will share their organization's
mission and role in this endeavor
as well as their insights on how we as
an industry
can continue to take these important
steps together for the future
we hope that you find their work as
inspiring as we do
it is now my pleasure to turn things
over to my colleague
tony leganz director of diversity and
inclusion for 2k
who will be the moderator for today's
discussion thanks alan
it's my pleasure to be your moderator
for today's session
before we begin i'd like to introduce my
steam panelists today
we're going to start off with jim
huntley jim huntley is currently the
professor
and head of marketing at usc jim is a
faculty advisor
and he's an executive producer for usc
games expo
and a co-founding partner of pac-u
gaming
next we have susanna pollock susanna is
the president of games for change which
is a non-profit
that empowers in creators and social
innovators to drive real world impact
through games and immersive media
next to susanna we have gordon bellamy
gordon is a professor of practice of
cinematograph arts at usc
he is also the head of usc bridge
incubator
which is a program that helps to
cultivate the next generation of leaders
in
in the video game industry and last
next to gordon we have laila shabir
leila is the founder of girls make games
which offers
a series of summer camps workshops and
game jams
designed to expire inspire the next
generation
of designers creators and engineers
welcome to all of you great panelists
and thank you so much for joining our
important discussion today
now i'd like to dive right in here and
jim i'm going to start with you
in allen's opening he mentioned
something that was so important and it
was really just talking about the
increasing role
that diversity equity and inclusion it
is playing in the video game industry
today
so before we get into the big concepts
that we're talking about
here let's just break some things down
for our viewers
jim can you help us understand and talk
about
equity and diversity and why it's so
important
in the conversation about the video game
industry today
absolutely um equity and diversity has
been a challenge for the gaming industry
since its inception uh it hasn't really
changed
very very much over time but i think the
biggest change people are seeing in the
last two to three years are
the lack of it in the modern era and the
rationale that there's no excuse behind
not having better equity and diversity
in the industry from here on out so what
i like about working with companies like
take two and some other companies have
reached out to me about
an initiative we started to call the uh
the gerald a lawson
endowment fund is that companies are now
looking to invest in getting
more uh diversity in their ranks and
getting more stories told from different
points of view
i appreciate that that's great
conversation there um so let's talk
about just kind of the inequities and
why is it so important to have these
conversations
talk about that whole aspect and just
getting people
in the right mindset to understand
what's available for them as majors in
this industry
jim talk to us a little bit about that
absolutely so
a lot of uh what we've been focusing on
from a usc games perspective
is making sure that students of color
black and indigenous students in
particular because they have
the least amount of representation
within our industry out of all the
various demographic groups uh we've been
focusing on scholarships but
the challenge that we have and i think
the challenge that society and the
industry has is
it starts earlier than that there's a
phrase from i can't remember to
attribute to but there's a phrase of
these i remember
saying the inequities of our past paid
dividends into the future
and that sticks with me because the
reality is if you don't have a great
opportunity or access to computer
science labs and specialized
education in grade school in high school
and junior high school
the odds of you having a great portfolio
piece when it comes time to apply to a
program like ours puts you at a deficit
and if that
deficit keeps rolling on into the future
generation after generation
the gap between the ability to get into
some of these uh
slots in game design and not being able
to get them
gets wider and wider so we need to do a
better job as a society and we're we we
are willing to do our part and help work
with companies like take to leave the
vanguard on
how do we get students some opportunity
from grade school like how do we make
sure they can see this as an option
because
when when i as a black man get in front
of a small group of you know grade
school students and i say i work in the
video game industry you can see the eyes
just
their minds explode because they've
never seen anyone like me
and the videos they see on youtube or
other visitors to their classes
to their seminars so uh it's important
to show that we have
uh presence here but it's also important
to make sure that the students who look
like us
who are you know 20 years 30 years 40
years behind us also have the
opportunities that um
we didn't in some cases to get a job in
this
uh industry yes thank you so much for
your insight so important there
susannah that really kind of speaks to a
lot of the great work that you're doing
in helping to reach this
underserved community can you talk about
the work that games for change is doing
sure um so you know our mission as you
said earlier is to empower
game designers and social innovators
right to use
games for uh social change and
we see our work with younger people is
really inspiring the next generation
right and so just what jim was saying
like we are going
as young we're going as young as sixth
grade sometimes fifth grade but trying
to
um give young people and mostly entitled
entitled one school so those are schools
that qualify for free lunches which
often are representing the
underserved communities an opportunity
to
um to dive in in deeply into
this gaming industry this this um
experience they all love to do
and help them become creators of this
content not just consumers
and it's we've been finding that the
program that we've been running called
the games for change student challenge
we've been running it for the past
six years uh we've reached over 30 000
young people um in middle and high
school
and we not only give them an opportunity
to learn how to make
games um but they we also combine that
with civic
engagement so they have to think about
how games can help make their
communities better
so right from the start we want to
empower them to think about this really
important medium not only as something
they love to do
but they actually can make they're
learning uh
important 21st century and and stem
skills
that can help them regardless of what
career path
but what we really hope to see happen is
that they see a future for themselves
and they see an opportunity a pathway
for them
and a part of our program an important
part of it is this idea of
mentoring and mentoring from near peers
and also from people from the community
so as jim says it's so important they
see themselves in the people that are
coming to speak to them
so when we're in los angeles for example
we can reach out to us
um you know usc games um
for uh game design students to come and
speak to the kids that we can bring
people in from riot or activision
or from take two to come in and say yes
this is what i do
and this is something for you and we do
the same thing in new york and working
in atlanta and detroit
and i can tell you that that students
are coming back year on year and we're
seeing them
use this program as like their college
essay
or they're building their portfolio and
i love the idea that
you know we can we can get to them at a
young age
they spend their summers with layla at
girls make games and then they can go on
and apply to college
you know and we were talking about this
pipeline or
or you know this pathway for them um
and so that's the role in what we hope
to to inspire
i love what you said there suzanne
there's so many little nuggets that you
just
pulled out there um the different the
different avenues you can have and
career pathways there are in the gaming
industry
um just the activity that you can have
in terms of having mentorship
and role models and representation and
just you know having
good gamers out there so there's so many
things that you talked about that i want
to hit on
let's just pull layla into this
conversation and just talk about the
idea the idea of mentorship and
representation
leila talk about the workshops and the
summer programs that you offer to girls
how does that help
to increase the representation and the
mentorship aspects that we've talked
about
thanks so much for having me i was on
mute this is 20 21
it's still going on here um but like
susanna said i think it's really
important to kind of pass that baton on
and i think we see the summer after
summer
having created a place that's you know
for girls we get this question a lot why
do you need a space that's just for
girls there's so many programs out there
that are open to everyone
but i think it's just so important to
create that space because
like jim talked about it's so important
to see people who are like yourselves
for many of the girls that come to camp
this is their first time walking into a
room full of girls who love video games
you know they've been so accustomed to
kind of being the only girl in
on their robotics team or the only girl
that went to a coding camp with their
brother
and the the girl who's fighting her
brothers for for you know the
xbox controller so those are very common
themes and stories and i think
it's important to kind of tie in not
just the the mentorship but also the
community
it's very important to walk into a room
and feel like you're not an outsider
and the best way to do that is to show
many more faces that look just like you
it's really validating to walk away not
just with the technical skills but to
feel like
these are people that are gonna you know
kind of encounter
in 10 15 years and we'll be like
professionals because right now we're
just kids making games so we'll be
professionals in a few years
and seven years out for girls make games
we're finally starting to see
you know these girls kind of make plans
together to go to college and and
this year i would say like the first
time we got in like dozens of emails
from families saying you know my
daughter is now
thinking of college and how do we get
this portfolio going
um how do we set that up so i think
touching on jim's point too
there's so many challenges that you know
people have to go through just to get
everything right you shouldn't have to
rely on luck so much so if you look at
the women who are now
excelling and thriving in the industry
and you ask them their stories
so many things had to go right in their
lives to finally end up in the industry
many of whom ended up there accidentally
like me and even tony
i think tony and i touched on that
earlier but it shouldn't have to be
luck or accident it we can actually
intentionally create these pipelines and
i think it requires all of us working
together
like everyone in this room talking about
what we're doing and how do we
pass our students on from you know we
start as young as eight
um getting them on to the programs and
then passing them on to the student
challenge and then on to usc
and then finally on to the industry i
think that would be
that's basically that the magic formula
to solving the problem that we're
talking about today
yes i thank you for getting on that
pipeline challenge and actually solution
um you really clearly laid it out there
for us i really really enjoy that
um and something else you mentioned is
just like really opening this world of
gaming to
new diverse um a pool
pool and a spectrum of gamers and how do
we create those real
pathways back into the gaming industry
gordon you've done a lot of work in just
helping to
create value where value was not seen in
in places in the gaming industry
specifically for the gay gaming
professionals
can you talk about how the
representation and widening the spectrum
of what gaming professional looks like
and how your company
and your role really accomplishes that
sure
um so we have a mission which is focused
on
uh education uh employment
expertise and entrepreneurship and
the reason why is because alongside
diversity and equity inclusion there's a
new word that's come a lot which is
belonging right
a feeling of belonging of of being
default
and i know that uh
people in their uniqueness do a lot of
mental um socioeconomic
and sometimes social gymnastics before
they get to be as good as they are
before they get a chance to participate
in this panel
or participate in our industry by and
large
and i think the work that we all share
is trying to disrupt some of those
mental gymnastics
social economic gymnastics social
gymnastics
that young women people of color
indigenous people neurodiverse people
need to do in order to be as great as
they
are you know to belong you know in the
space and
sort of hearing you know what layla is
speaking to of
a cohort right that treats
each other as defaulted where are we
gonna go now together
collectively uh the program you know
jim's putting in place
right with the endowment uh honoring
lawson
where there's going to be cohorts of
black and indigenous people
right growing together and the work that
susana you've been doing since before it
was cool
okay you were changing games you know
making that dollar 15 cents before all
of us
um all of that
work um you know and with the support of
corporations like take two
right is enabling us to move a
generation forward
specifically with ggp of we have a
scholars program
in partnership with take two some go to
usc
many go on to participate in games for
change and many have been
girls who made games um and that's where
we find ourselves intersecting
is that that that college point of uh
how do we take towards
professionalization
and then we hope to carry them through
into employment
into being experts right because that's
the real challenge we're trying to
discover people
you don't want just to be entering you
want experts
right and if things are going to really
change
like this discussion you need owners
right layla owner susanna owner
gym owner all of you owners of facets of
your business
right that is where we become
the batter not the frosting right
where the change is you know more than
we count
two percent three percent one percent
we aren't even the ones counting right
we're still being counted
right until you're doing the counting
nothing has changed right i don't need
to ask
how many young ladies are in girls make
games like all of them
right what is the gender balance of
games for change
i didn't all of it right
these sort of systemic changes like
that's
that is the work i think we all share i
think it's why we all made time today
right i've been to every e3 i was a
booth boy
when i started and i'm still here right
25 26 years later haven't missed one yet
so i hope that someone out there sees
this
and begins their path right and this is
additive
you know that's why we're all here
i appreciate that yes exactly what
you're saying there's so much more that
all of us can be doing the
accountability piece is really very
important gordon thank you for bringing
that up
i just want to lay this out there to all
our panelists
what can corporations do to really set
themselves up for success in the near
future
and grabbing this new talent this talent
out there that we need to capture to
help us build
better more relevant engaging video
games
what can corporations do so i was
thinking about this
in particular as um as gordon was
talking about the scholarships that
um that he puts forward so having core
organizations companies like take two
have
a um to be visible to young people
not just because they're buying you know
they're downloading the games off of
um whatever off of xbox or playstation
but because they're there in front at
the from the beginning and so
take two has been part of our challenge
since the beginning offering
scholarships to our grand prize winners
and i can tell you that that's a
motivator for kids
to participate not just because there's
a scholarship at the end but it's
because take two
is part of it like it made us cool right
and
and i think it's that relationship at
that young of an age
um that um that
that makes a connection with people is
like yeah they they want to hear what i
have to say
right like they're here because this
program exists and because i'm
interested in doing it
and i think that kind of relationship
with these kids
whether they're mentoring and coming
into a classroom they're pretty they're
volunteering at a game jam
or judging games at the end of the
competition they're involved and i think
that plays a
it really has an impact on young kids
lives yes
i love that i just want to add to what's
interesting i think that
um and so i mean we're talking about
take two and thank you for having us
um is making the success
of black people of women
of queer people of indigenous people
neurodiverse people
a business goal
the same way that the consumption right
of content
right get some downloadable skins buy
some
nba 2k right that that's a business goal
around which the business aligned and i
feel as though
if the expertise of women
black people neurodiverse
other populations was a business goal
then that would be the change it'd be
that simple but oh we're
our business is more successful if there
is more of this
right and that's about people being
of value versus just being valuable
which are two different things there's
lots of exceptional people
right who are of value in spite of their
circumstances
they're valuable right there's a
difference between saying
you're of value and that's a business
goal
in itself and i think that's the
corporate
that's the real the real change because
it used to be
i mean just real talk it used to be
about exceptionalism
right and be like oh you're able to
thrive under this duress
right in that cool versus
right you are actually who we are so we
are going to cultivate you
that's who we are year round that's
what we look like what we sound like
right
who we are right and so
as the lever moves more towards that
right
the same way like i have biases i
attended harvard college
so i'm a value right there's value in
that right i'm treated that way
in some circles if the same lens
was put onto women onto brown people
black people
queer people then look
who there'd be no as the kids say no cap
on the change that could take place
right
right and that just speaks to being
deliberate with our diversity
inclusion equity practices corporations
really have to take that accountability
and like you said do what's right in in
that
in that spectrum in that conversation
looking at value from different sources
and kind of recalibrating our minds to
that
but like you guys have said it takes
time it takes starting earlier
in the pipeline i love that you just
call that out what other things can
corporations do
that are just different different than
what we've been doing in the past
perhaps
what would you recommend i would even
add to what gordon just said um
the the looking at uh this challenge as
a business
challenge is is key that's what uh
between the inspiration of the
the social justice marches from last
summer and really uh
talking to our chair danny bilson who
said that hey if you were going to
tackle this issue this giant
generational issue
as a business problem what would you do
and that flipped the light switch on for
me
well of course like any business problem
what are my challenges i've got
uh gaps in my supply chain if you will
so how do i fill those gaps in my supply
chain and really
working your way backwards in a way
where you're putting um
objectives strategies and tactics in
place to achieve those goals from a
business perspective
you're going to see outcome when it's
not just hey here's a check and good
luck with charity x it's going to be
more
okay here's a check this is what we're
hoping to see let's measure along the
way and see if we're
seeing progress on that and it's the
measurement of progress and adjusting in
real time based on the data that you're
getting back
that's where you're going to meet that's
where you're going to see the the gap
start to close in a meaningful way
and be able to point out to other people
in the industry like hey
this is what we can all do together what
if we scale this
effort up and really had an impact on
society as a whole
um that mindset is is really going to be
what changes the game
so i like to i like to think about it as
like a pie
you know when we think about like from
like a corporate strategy we always
think about
there's a piece of the pie and everyone
gets a little piece of the pie
but i think the way we have to approach
this is really
pie is not a fixed size i think by
including more people the pie gets
bigger
so it's not a fixed size that we're
trying to all get a piece of
but by including more people you know in
the industry
by becoming creators of this medium we
actually expand the medium
expanded beyond just entertainment i
think that speaks
really heavily to me as a problem solver
is like when i look at video games
it's such an underutilized tool for
social change
and i think like that i can see susannah
kind of has been on the forefront of
that and
coming in as an outsider to the games
industry i was just kind of blown away
that oh my god you can do so much like
nine out of ten kids play video games
you know not nine out of ten boys nine
out of ten kids we're talking about
literally changing perceptions and
inspiring and educating
generation after generation and yet that
power rests in the hand of like a select
few
and i think when you think about it not
just from a corporate responsibility but
as a social responsibility like what are
we putting out there
for our kids to consume i think we need
to bring in
pretty much everyone anyone and everyone
who's interested in building a future
together
in that so between the pie and the
corporate responsibility i feel like
there's a lot that
that gets lost like i think there's a
big dichotomy between these are people
that are doing good and these are people
that are
self-serving but it doesn't work like
that we have to work together and
everyone does kind of go
between what's good for me and what's
good for everyone
you know so thank you for bringing that
concept
up layla the codependency we are all
community members in this pipeline and
we have to be active deliberate
in our processes in our systems how we
tackle this problem
uh before we end this conversation
there's tons of questions that we have
that we want to ask you so i'm going to
pause right now
and give our esteemed questioneers
a chance to ask their questions that are
top of mind related to our conversation
today
[Music]
so we're going to start off with some
questions from our
other video game industry experts here
we've got carrie she's an executive
producer from private division
we also have vanetta who's a director of
talent acquisition with take two
and nier he's the head of mobile for
take two
so go ahead and fire it away awesome
thank you tony um the first question is
for
layla but certainly open to having the
rest of our panelists answer the
question
but at the beginning of your career did
you
ever imagine being a leader within an
industry that is predominantly male
dominated and what is your
advice for other young women that are
interested in taking a similar path to
where you are today
um thank you juanetta um i don't think i
really envisioned being in a male
dominated industry although i did
envision being in a male-dominated world
because i grew up in the middle east and
i was painfully aware of being a girl
and how my life was going to turn out to
be different from from
my male peers or my brothers or my
cousins or any of that
i was fortunate that my my parents were
very supportive and they wanted me to
pursue whatever dream i wanted
but i think having that mindset and
coming from a world that was very much
male dominated
already prepared me for you know hey
whatever i end up doing there's going to
be more boys or men
um than me i think the piece of advice
that i would really give girls is to
honestly not think about your gender
when you think about what you want to
pursue
because it's all about you specifically
you might end up liking things that
people even your age your geographic
location
your you know educational background or
your family might not have heard of or
even thought of and that is
all the things that i ended up doing
were things that didn't match
anything that i had seen in my own
environment but i just kind of pursued
what i wanted to
and then two is to kind of use a very
selective
um hearing i think you have to kind of
develop selective hearing
listen to the people that care about you
that love you and encourage you
in being more of who you are and
diminish the voices
of people who say you can't do things
because
it's never been done or that's not how
it is or that's not how the
world works the way the world works is
is based on the world that we build and
we're continually building a new world
so it doesn't matter how things are done
now
they're gonna be done a different way as
you grow up and you can be part of
building that world
so those would be like my two pieces of
advice for for girls is to just pursue
what you want and
you know develop selective hearing
all right um my question is versus xana
but also i'm open to anyone else who
would like to answer
um and i think gordon kind of hit it uh
earlier when
he said uh that you know most of us
didn't have
it didn't have a lot of examples there
were opportunities i'm in that boat i
didn't have any programs and
anyone telling me that i could do this
and definitely had to uh
not necessarily an accident but really
had to work uh
in a different way harder than most so
um so
my question suzanna for you is um can
you share an example of how your program
has
impacted someone that has participated
or you know a few people
sure um so as i said our program is six
years old we in new york city we've been
we're
a bit younger in in the other cities
that we're operating in and
and there are opportunities now that
kids all over the country can can
uh can participate um but we saw in new
york
um a very particularly strong cohort we
are actually in over 125 schools right
now in new york city
um and there are some rockstar teachers
that have encouraged their kids to
participate their participants year on
year and year
and that to me is is certainly the
beginning of getting
uh this kind of program off the ground
and particularly in schools that where
where students usually aren't offered
this kind of experience
so one having the teachers um uh
find value and really and and and work
to
uh well and making a part of an annual
program within their school system has
also allowed
students to continue with the program
year on year
um there's one uh young woman in
particular who won
i think she won the um like our theme
category the first
time round um when she participated as a
sophomore
the junior um or junior year she won
again and by the senior year
she was a grand prize winner in new york
city and i hear
that she then followed on with a full
scholarship to nyu game center
right and and it was just amazing and i
just remember
she was invited to speak at the games
for change festival after she won
um it must have been the second year i
don't think it was the third year
um and she came and we were having a
panel a conversation about you know the
program
and she was invited to speak on it and
her father came with her
and followed her around the entire like
two days she was there with a camera
recording her experience
in this you know professional
environment not only when she was
speaking but she was sitting and
watching the other people on stage
and it was so awesome to see that kind
of support
within her family i'm like all right
you've got educators supporting this
young woman
this pathway you've got her family and
and actually since she graduated i've
seen other kids in her family come
through the program
but it takes that kind of multiple
supports from different directions to
really
support this young woman who is a woman
of color from
uh brooklyn um who uh
found her path right and she got the
right supports and and she
and she got there and now um i also
understand that she's launched her own
studio and is raising money
uh you know a kickstarter she's
remarkable
that's awesome thanks for sharing that
story that's so cool
near do you have a question for our
panelists
yeah hi i do so my question is to gordon
um i'm looking at lgbtq representation
in gaming i've been in gaming for
more than 12 years and and it feels
to me that uh representation
is a bit low than what you would expect
what i see in tech in other
sectors uh do you have some data or some
thoughts uh about that is that the fair
estimation and if so
why is that and what are the main
challenges that lgbtq individuals
face in in this industry sure
um well i'll tell you a little history
here so um
when we started ggp about 15 years ago
which is not that long ago in corporate
times
um queer people only existed on an
anonymous mailing list
anonymous to each other
okay because um employment safety
which is still a concern globally not to
mention just safety safety
was a number one concern which all of us
lived with so
you know even i and you know back then
you know weird flex but
i had designed madden football had
already sold a company to activision
employment safety so um
that is the number one reason why
um and just in this new recent history
have we begun to build the trust
and value in each other so as to
aggregate and to even acknowledge each
other
okay and to build systemic uh ties to
companies like
take two um
and others uh to to be
to move from um from hiding
from the industry right escaping from
the industry
to affinity right like oh
right to employee resource groups and
corporate leaders like tony existing
right and we're moving closer to being a
business resource
and so in other technology areas that
path is further along
where it is is like to say in the batter
that the queer identity is of value
and there's customers there's of course
creators
there's of course business leaders and
owners you know of all walks
and in the optimum business you would
cultivate you know
all types of people as a game craft we
are still in generation one
you even asking this question here you
you're a wild pioneer you are the out
there with your machete
chopping down bamboo to even ask this
question
which presumes that lgbt people would be
employed
okay and then in communication with each
other
right and communicate with each other
across different companies
and in any sort of ongoing concern so
welcome thank you for asking for those
of you at home we have a discord
and a facebook that you can all join and
participate
um at any time or you can reach out to
me directly on twitter gordon bellamy
um wherever you may be on or off your
path
as an lgbtqia person or an
ally right because i think that's
something we've all discovered
and i think um whatever population you
are part of
whether it be across gender or race
or expression identity is that you don't
have to be a member to care
okay you don't got to be a member to say
this is an important issue
and in fact a lot of the work that we do
at a corporate level
is saying hey you don't have to do all
the work
right you don't want to push the rock
that's sitting on you
we're going to help you push that rock
that's on you
it's not on me but i can help push right
because i can
see it it's on you
and so um asking these questions
um corporate support
time right three t's time talent and
treasure
you know we'll move this discussion
forward
i hope to answer your question here but
otherwise just get at me
i can you know tell you more and anyone
else who's watching
we could tell you more in greater detail
jordan i know your
company has some things going on in the
cup few months
talk about some of the activities you
guys have sure sure
um so we have most of our content
now in addition to our scholars program
and our
our community service that we do with
take two is streaming
so we stream front page of twitch and we
bring it to youtube
um content around equity inclusion
belonging and
not just lgbt um we just had our second
uh indigenous game creators panel
yesterday big hit
because you know what indigenous
creation has always been here
always been here um in
august we're going to be doing our first
ggp honors which is going to be honoring
the best
in diversity equity inclusion and
belonging in our craft
so we're going to be lifting up the
people who do the work
right every day in our ergs
in our executive suites like dr liggins
right these people
need to be cultivated as well right
the same way we cultivate engineers
artists
and other things that we value right
things that we value need to be
cultivated so we're going to be getting
do that work
august tune in front page of twitch it's
going to be a mood
hope you're all there awesome thank you
we probably have time for one more
question so let's go for it
who's got their last burning question
for our panelists
oh i have several questions
one um we'll just speak i have to come
from the affinity group erg
perspective so gordon thank you for
touching on that so this question is for
both jim
and gordon as someone that you know
represents a
member of an erg as well as a leader of
an erg
what advice would you give ergs
affinity groups brgs that are either
just starting out
or those that are established in
organizations that are
looking for ways to further embed
themselves
into the business so that that better
versus thing that you're talking about
also i mean to add to that i think the
um something that we've
a few of us have touched on earlier is
uh an old adage from from
the business world you can't manage what
you can't measure uh if you don't have a
way to see how your progress is
is evolving over a continuum you kind of
just go well i think something's working
let's just keep doing that and
uh business people myself being one of
them don't respond well to that it's
just
okay let's just keep investing in a
thing that i don't know the results of
you need to be able to go back and say
hey this year we were here
this following year we were here here's
the you know not only
have we seen a positive impact on the
investment or good roi
but we also recognize the fact that the
partner and partners that we're working
with
are making moves and making investments
into the future that they're saying that
they want to see
those the positive feedback loop of
being able to say here's data that shows
that
what we're doing is having an impact on
our objectives and
rewarding that partner or those partners
for that investment for that support
that's really key to building a positive
feedback loop around investing in
diversity equity inclusion
yeah yeah what jim said but i'd still
say make it mobile
god if you could move that needle like
point two percent anything
you can't get cut you can't get cut then
right there's no way
no today budget's tight when you're
moving that needle 0.2 percent
right well the skill the scale would
which we all operate
it's pretty staggering when you think
about it when you aggregate how much
revenue and profit goes and chris
probably goes in the games business
for the for a meaningful uh moving of
the needle of dei
comparatively speaking it's not a huge
amount of money um it's you know
to have a really big demonstrable impact
measurable impact
um if we aggregate our dollars and
really focus on some key objectives we
can really move the needle in a way if
it's gonna
frankly when you start seeing things
work people get excited uh it work let's
keep doing it let's keep doing it and it
gets bigger and bigger and bigger and
that's
why the lawson fund is what it is it's
an endowment because we want to see
uh and have an impact in the aggregate
over time over generations and and
support
students for decades to come um not just
have it be uh
this fiscal year what can we do yeah
awesome thank you
one more thing just let it go is just
keep saying black out loud
right let's get back to to black is
beautiful we've been residing in black
lives matter for a long time and we need
to be back to like black and proud
and black and beautiful and so your
existence
right and saying it and saying positive
outcomes
after the word black is meaningful
each and every day that you can do it in
your erg
i love that thank you good question
we've got time for more what else do we
have
all right i'll go if we have time for
more um
uh layla how how have you been able to
like come
actually connect with the people in the
community um
for to bring awareness for your programs
like how do you actually gather people
um you know to participate and
especially like in the very beginning
oh my gosh so the first camp in 2014 we
literally like
barged into a maker faire with flyers
and we were
just going around and being like you
look like you would love video games
because you're playing with robots right
now
so come to our camp but i think it's um
it's pretty much primarily been word of
mouth originally but then
when we ended up partnering with the
game studios and game companies that
really helped
elevate um the program and the pr i
think suzanne touched on that it's like
it actually legitimized us
and then kind of made us really cool
like hey you can go make games
at you know these game studios you can
actually make a game at xbox it's a
playstation nintendo take two
you can go into their offices meet the
developers and make these games and i
think that
cool factor has kind of really helped us
out
when it comes to speakers and people who
want to mentor and be involved that's
been a lot easier because
you know a lot of our teachers end up
being college students themselves and
they they come back and
they'll say things like i wish this
program existed when i was younger
uh it sucks i couldn't go to it but at
least i get to be a part of it and give
back to the kids and then
same thing for mentors and speakers um
there's so much interest
in in wanting to give back and wanting
to welcome
new voices into the industry we just
haven't we haven't really had to do a
lot of pushing
you know in fact we get pulled in a lot
of directions i was talking to my team
the other day i was like this is a very
fortunate problem to have we're
we're getting pulled in 100 directions
because we're needed in 100 directions
as opposed to
us telling people that hey this is
important pay attention and you know
look at what we're doing so um yeah it's
i would say it's been very organic and
really the tide is turning you know
we're building a new industry
we're building on the industry that we
have we're also building a new
part of the industry together so it's
really exciting
thank you thanks laila and thank you to
our panelists you guys have been very
inspirational
um very thought provoking and have less
left us with a lot of great
tidbits to take away to take back to our
corporations and our respective
organizations
to really make a deliberate impact in
our community that we're building
and this whole world of diversity and
equity and inclusion in the video game
industry
so thank you all thank you the viewers
for joining and um
have fun at the virtual e3 conference
[Music]
i think ever since mega man x i've just
loved the sort of 8-bit 16-bit
pixel art style as an artist i just kind
of fell in love with that aesthetic
number one mega man x favorite game of
all time whenever somebody asks me the
deserted on a
on an islands question mega man x is the
game i would say
tomb raider lara croft is the reason why
i started to become
really adventurous in my own life and
wanted to be
as intelligent and curious uh
and brave as her grand theft auto san
andreas
i feel like that was the first video
game that i've ever played
where i've seen so many black people in
one game
and felt like oh my gosh my people you
got the eisley brothers playing on the
radio like oh yes
this is where i need to be for rap of
the rapper
on playstation man bring that back
playstation
uh perhaps we've got more bars than half
the industry right now so i recommend
that you all go check it out because
it's one of my favorites i think it
might be apex legends and i know
you know the thing you're most excited
about is the thing that you've just done
but truly i have been waiting my entire
life
to play a character like well and
yeah it's changed my life my favorite
game is without question absolutely
league of legends
it's been like a decade since release
and it's still just at the top of the
charts and
it's where i go with all my friends and
hang out it's my go-to
that was the first female i actually
ever seen play video games as my mother
and she loved double 07 and we would all
play me my brother my mother and my dad
and we would just we would just go crazy
in that game have game nights and
everything
lion king sega ortega cause that will
teach you about life
right quick that
was hard
you